j'ai bien fermé laver les mains on va
remettre veille à la sécurité qu'on a
établi aujourd'hui on établit avec une
infirmière connaît tout le procès des
deux zones trop vide
on a fait les normes sanitaires de
nettoyage de stérilisation de
l'équipement avant mais on leur faire
pendant on s'est habillée selon les
normes comme sont rentrés dans une salle
peu vide rappelle luc vincent je suis
coiffard une conversation avec une dame
au téléphone nu quelques semaines et on
parle on parle et la dame médias moment
donné mais ça je me suis fait coiffer
toutes les semaines toute ma vie a dit
moi mon dernier petit plaisir qui me
restait c'était de me faire quoi fils
mercredi puis d'aller manger avec ma
fille sentiments et là ça s'est mis à me
mijoter dans ma tête et loge vip pendant
que moi je suis disponible pourquoi
j'irais pas en toute sécurité et l'ordre
donné d'un moment de réconfort
[Musique]
désinfectez qui est lavable on va le
mettre dans un sac a pas
[Musique]
tous les coiffeurs peuvent faire ce que
j'ai fait aujourd'hui
oui non on ne peut pas le faire sans
être supervisés janvier chaque cliente
avait son propre camp 6 open et c'est le
changement de bien se faisait entre
chaque client au moment quelqu'un avec
les champs on faisait le changement du
gain et on avait une infirmière qui
regardaient toute l'équipe
même votre équipe de tournage sans arrêt
pour s'assurer qu'il y avait une
sécurité maximum dans le monde
[Musique]
il ya sûrement des centres de personnes
âgées qui pourraient recevoir des
coiffeurs avec une formation et qu'on
pourrait aller donner un premier coup de
main bénévole et ensuite chaque fois
ford pourrait rentrer à son salon a
commencé son métier en dix ans brigitte
et donner un coup de main la société
[Musique]
talent vous avez c'est plus que la cour
fois que j'ai fait cela induit c'est
plus que ça
je vous pose une question qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous en ce moment du chrono
virus chico von finck russell verrue
cela s'est produit qui va être beau cv +
août s'est toujours donné du bonheur en
un moment de deux moments de bonheur un
moment que les et un moment où les gens
vont se sentir bien
personne ne peut me dire en ce moment
que de ce fait les cheveux c'est
superficiel là aujourd'hui on a osé
couper des cheveux pour juste dans une
normalité à ses jambes
[Musique]
on est là on pense à vous autres vous
êtes dans la société vous faites parties
pour trouver un moyen pour vous
rejoindre
on vous laisse pas tomber c'est ce que
je peux le faire aujourd'hui à travers
le métier que je fais qui est de couper
des cheveux
j'avais été traité comme ça je ne
t'oublie de vous